[Música]
buenas tardes sabías que la suma de tus
esfuerzos te pueden dar resultados y
esos resultados pueden ser
potencializados a éxito
yo soy si nueve pasos soy director
general de un hospital privado de la
cadena más grande de méxico y américa
latina
lo que ves aquí es lo que comúnmente
puedes encontrar en una organización en
una formación en donde la empresa te
enseña que hay jerarquías que hay
niveles esto es una pirámide lo puedes
ver también en una organización como un
organigrama yo entré en este grupo en
1998 en la estructura más baja de la
organización como auxiliar
administrativo en aquel entonces pues
era auxiliar donde se grababa desangra
pavas
quizá en ese momento no te estaba
generando un aprendizaje
en ese momento yo también estudiaba y
pues tus sueños son ser alguien en la
vida
lo que me enseñó esta organización y
sobre todo quisiera enfocarme a que me
llevó a donde estoy hoy
no es hablarte de la empresa sino
hablarte de lo que me ayudó y que te
quiero que hoy te lleves como un
aprendizaje que el día de hoy si tú
formas parte una empresa o de una
organización aprendas algunas técnicas
que hoy a mí me ayudaron
en esta línea de bateo tú lo que tienes
que entender
es que hay una fórmula para poder crecer
y esa línea de bateo tiene que enseñarte
algo algo en la vida para que puedas
ofrecerle a los demás
normalmente
y quiero llevar el ejemplo de la
siguiente manera
en un juego
en el que ustedes gusten en cualquier
deporte en cualquier deporte en donde tú
puedas identificar un espectador la vida
es así te vas a encontrar mucha gente
que son espectadores y sabes qué es lo
que piensan de repente el espectador que
gana o que pierde se ríe llora
piensa que su equipo ganó o perdió
te juzga de crítica te insulta y así en
la vida nos encontramos mucha gente
como espectadores como gente que
solamente observa pero no está en la
posición en la que tú juegas
con eso en este tipo de gente
comentaristas gente experta que quizás
jugaron el balón que también lo tocaron
queda mejor tienen la razón y tienen el
conocimiento para poder juzgar narran
cuánta gente encontramos así gente
experta gente que nos dice cómo aunque
lo mejor nunca han tocado el balón
pero creo que en la vida para poder
crecer en una organización o en lo que
tú pretendas hacer tienes que jugar el
papel de jugador de aquel que se
esfuerza este hombre que tú ves aquí
aunque no te gusta el deporte sabes
quién es porque trascendió porque
demostró quién era él porque jugó un
balón porque perdió nueve mil veces ese
balón y inclusive en juegos de la nba en
el último tiro falló
y así es la vida te enseña a esforzarte
te enseña a sumar
ese jugador me convertía en la empresa
el no juzgar a mis compañeros el no
criticar si el de sumar eso me llevó
algún amigo me dijo en algún momento si
no me vas a llegar muy lejos y si llegue
muy lejos visité todo el país como en la
contraloría donde yo trabajaba en ese
grupo donde me invitaron a participar y
a sumar
a que el aprendizaje y el conocimiento
te lleva al resultado
eso me llevó también a entender que
retos que hay retos y que vas creciendo
esta empresa tiene más de 10.000
empleados y será hoy el número 42 o 30
que importa
que importa el número lo que importa es
lo que haces todos los días lo que
importa es que sumes a ese resultado
cuando me ofrecieron esta dirección me
dijo la organización si 9
vamos a demostrar de lo que estás hecho
esta unidad de negocios lleva seis años
de pérdida acumulada está en 'números
rojos'
además tienes que sumar que no hay una
conexión con la comunidad
este hospital se encuentra en tampico
tampoco está sumado con la comunidad
médica
y si eso le quieres también agregar que
tú no conoces a nadie en tampico
asume el reto estás listo yo entré me
dije pues a lo mejor si me quieren
correr pero me hubieran dicho antes
y bueno esta posibilidad se logra a
través de ese esfuerzo pero quisiera
también compartir contigo y que esta
tarde te lleves a algún otro aprendizaje
y aprendimos el ser jugador pero ahora
que vamos a aprender
porque eso es lo que hacemos todos que
hemos descubierto para poder llegar
hasta donde queremos ir lo que hemos
realmente logrado para poderlo llegar
hasta donde llegó ese hombre que se
llama michael jordan amar lo que haces
pasión a lo que haces que si vas a ser
el mejor jugador se el mejor jugador del
mundo que si te vas a levantar hoy
y te vas a hacer un enojo de un enojo
profesional por favor no sé es un enojo
mediocre e
pero hazlo de veras esfuérzate para que
eso suceda
y si vas a ser un crítico puse un
crítico a un profesional con elementos
con fundamentos
llegué a este lugar y lo primero que
hice es tomar
la tierra de este lugar amarla y
respetarla respetar sus costumbres
entender qué es lo que se tiene que
hacer y cómo resolverlo
y te voy a compartir otra de las
técnicas que he aprendido durante estos
años ya son 20 años en este grupo
y mira el conocimiento
es la aptitud y la aptitud hoy la debes
tener para triunfar
pero no solamente necesitas eso o ya no
nada más necesitas conocer tener una
maestría un doctorado eso no te lleva al
éxito y no digo que no estudies es
fundamental pero eso es ya la base con
la que debes de contar
y actitud
75% de actitud 35
de aptitud la actitud es el cambio y ese
cambio te lleva a un éxito del 110%
has escuchado cuando te dicen datos 100%
no es necesario hoy el 100 por ciento
hoy necesitamos más hoy para que puedas
sobresalir necesitas más de 100%
te pido nada más el 10 más
que te esfuerces para que lo logres
porque el 100 ya lo están dando mucha
gente pero si quieres sobresalir después
de 8.000 o 10.000 empleados y llegar al
número 32 30 o poder ser el dueño de la
organización si algún día lo decides eso
es lo que tienes que hacer dar el 110% y
sabes qué
surge la magia
cuando me entregaron este hospital me lo
entregaron con un paciente
imagínense que llegué
y le pregunté a la supervisora de
enfermería oiga cuántos pacientes
tenemos y me dice
y uno ya se va
y luego pues regale la noche que sigue
porque me va a quedar sin pacientes
eso sucede y eso es una realidad
al día de hoy las cirugías han crecido
al 500 por ciento
productividad
actitud
y fíjate algo muy interesante recuerdas
esta pirámide esta pirámide que
en toda organización conoces y desde
donde comencé bueno esta unidad de
negocios que hoy dirijo me encuentro
hasta arriba
y cuando piensas que estás hasta arriba
y cuando piensas que después de 20 años
en la organización lo sabes todo es
momento de comenzar
y cuando piensas que eres el mejor
olvídate de que eres el mejor
porque tienes que seguir aprendiendo
porque la vida te da más enseñanza
porque la vida te da más fuerza para
seguir adelante
y entonces cuando era el de hasta arriba
comienza una nueva historia y trabajas
el triángulo invertido que hoy las
empresas deberían de hacer el más
importante no eres tú como director el
más importante es tu gente
y entonces inviertes la pirámide y
empiezas a ser un facilitador de arriba
hacia abajo de abajo hacia arriba
y entonces todos se empiezan a ser
importantes tus clientes tus pacientes a
lo que tú te dediques
tienes que enseñarle todo ese
aprendizaje a tu gente
tienes que ser un coach organizacional
para que la gente produzca pero porque
produzca con amor compasión a lo que
hace
para que alguien se respete no es el que
está en la dirección general sino al que
está en la el último eslabón
y es allí donde surge la magia y es a
donde ahí puedes generar todo lo que hoy
eres
conocen esta palabra la han escuchado en
algún momento
se puede sí se puede alguien me puede
ayudar si se puede si se puede si se
puede sí se pudo
eso es lo que tenemos que lograr ya no
es el intento de querer hacer las cosas
sino de hacerlas de adeveras y demostrar
que tú puedes
eso es energía eso es pasión a lo que
haces y sabes qué
que cuando piensas que ya estás dando el
máximo tienes que sentir el músculo cómo
se mueve cómo calienta
y cuando sientas eso y cuando sientas
llorar y cuando sientas el sudor y
cuando sientes el amor por lo que haces
y cuando sientas que ya va a reventar el
músculo apenas estás empezando a
trabajar si hoy no lo sientes
probablemente no llegues
y si hoy no lo sientes probablemente no
surja nada
porque la ley de las probabilidades
existe pero también la ley de los
porcentajes y si estás en una línea de
bateo
y lo entrenas y lo entrenas y lo
entrenas y lo entrenas llegas a una
maestría y cuando lo haces tantas veces
de forma repetida llegas a ser de los
mejores
hoy el tiempo
y la fórmula que te lleva a entender que
tenemos que regresar
a la posición
vas a recodificar tu mente y que el
tiempo es lo más precioso que hoy tienes
para poderlo aprovechar
hazlo hoy
tras lo pensando no por demostrarle a
los demás
sino porque tú crees en ti
el tiempo recuerda que es el único
recurso no renovable ya no regresa ya no
dejen las cosas para mañana eso no
sucede hoy hay gente compitiendo hoy hay
gente esforzándose
hoy hay gente decidida a dar lo mejor
pero si se hace tiempo lo aprovechas
y ese tiempo lo puedes hacer para que
generen más
seguramente el universo va
a juntar la energía para que tú progress
es algo que quiero compartir contigo
respecto al tiempo es también la
posibilidad de innovar hoy en las
empresas se maneja la misión visión y
valores
yo quiero agregar algo más
innovación
si tú no generas innovación en tu vida
si piensas que haciendo lo mismo todos
los días vas a obtener resultados
diferentes estás equivocado
tienes que innovar tienes que generar
algo diferente si hoy tú tienes una
empresa si te dedicas a algún trabajo si
tu trabajo es dar servicio
genera algo nuevo porque seguramente
otros te van a decir que dan la mejor
calidad que son los mejores eso todos lo
dicen pero que vas a ser diferente para
que se cobre valor esto que vas a ser
diferente para que hoy puedan lograr
resultados impresionantes saben cuánto
tiempo me dieron para levantar esta
empresa que lleva seis años tres meses
me dijeron solamente te damos tres meses
y si en tres meses no se levanta la
empresa vas de regreso
y en efecto tres meses no lo logré
no lo logré porque
la intención y las ganas de creer hacer
las cosas
y esa aptitud lograda a lo largo de
tantos años
pero la actitud de querer lograrlo
para el mayor porcentaje me llevo
a que esos tres meses
esos tres meses que probablemente te
pueden estresar y te puede llevar a
pensar que no lo vas a lograr
lo puedes hacer en el menor tiempo
posible y ese tiempo fue 30 días en 30
días logré que la empresa empezará a
registrar sus primeros números de
utilidad sus primeros números negros es
posible claro que es posible es posible
llevar a la cúspide de las empresas
claro que es posible como con ganas con
fortaleza
con mente con energía siendo positivo
ayudando a tus compañeros enseñándoles a
que no hay que ser tomadores de vida
sino dadores el ayudar a los asilos como
lo estábamos haciendo en tierra
en general héroes anónimos
el ya no juzgar porque la vida nos
enseña eso a juzgar pero sabes que hoy
te voy a compartir algo de lo más fuerte
que yo he recibido el aprendizaje y ese
poder lo tenemos todos y espero que hoy
tú también lo tomes como parte tuya hay
un poder
que se llama la elección tu eliges lo
que quieres en tu vida
hoy te invito a que elijas
qué charla el día de mañana vas a estar
dando aquí y que nos compartas esa
experiencia porque yo sé que allá afuera
hay experiencias enormes y grandes que
compartir el aprendizaje se genera todos
los días pero sobre todo el amor el amor
a tu familia el amor a lo que quieres la
pasión con la que sientes
porque tu vida es un abrir y cerrar de
ojos aprovecharla aprovecharlo al máximo
y espero que estas palabras te sirvan de
aliento para seguir adelante muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]